hi my name is Martin my chines name is
Yun here so you can call me Martin and
uh I used to work in qu hch fun in
London for about three years so um and
also I started uh PCH company in China
focusing on quantity trading uh systems
and uh you know uh trading some uh
signals as well so uh I come from a
Quant Trad in background I have a PhD in
computer science and um I've been using
uh python C+ Plus for a long time and
then I switched to Julia which is the
the language I'm going to talk about
today and I realized you know in uh
Quant trading uh there has been people
has been Quant uh hun using Julia
already so um so there's definitely an
opportunity for Julia to make a
difference uh in uh like qu of trading
industry but also in other industry as
well well and uh so today I'm going to
uh talk about uh you know how to use
Julia for
decentralization so um so uh can I have
uh like a quick PLL like uh how many
people have heard about Julia
before if you
uh
yeah uh
slides okay um okay no problem so uh
um um you know Julia has been uh there
for more than 10 years and uh um one
thing I normally uh would ask is how to
make Julia into the mainstream like
python you know a lot of Industry people
use Python and uh of course Julia is
also very popular in the uh scientific
Computing area and uh Julia has proven
itself to be the um um proven itself to
be the solution to a true language
problem so what I mean by the true
language problem is that um you know on
the one hand you have uh data scientists
and they usually do a lot of data
analytics and prototype and they have
the domain knowledge um they typically
use an easy to use uh language such as
python okay or math lab or R and uh they
normally talk to each other so that's uh
the one side okay and the on the other
side we have Engineers um programmers
developers who are more focusing on
systems okay they try to build systems
to extract all the uh performance from
the hardware given inside organization
so these two um are are two types of uh
you know culture you know um because the
the engineer the system people people
they typically use uh like C C++ which
is very sort of low level but the
performance is very great okay but for
um uh data scientists they use Python
which is easy to use but the performance
is not that great so we have this two
language problem okay and um typically
um within an organization you have to
have some mechanism to merge these two
you know to have some way first of all
Maybe you develop something in Python
and then you translate to in C++ which
happens in con hedge funds uh let's say
10 years or 15 years ago okay but then
Julia comes and Julia is a programming
language that is very easy to use uh
just like python or massab but also it's
very performance and it has proven
itself in the super Computing uh
industry and uh it has been used in
Lawrence Berkeley lab for you know
modeling you know um satellite images
and and so on so um definitely um Julia
has the potential to uh offer much more
than what uh we have seen today uh in
the industry and um what I believe u
what most people see is just the the
synthetic uh feature or the advantage of
Julia and uh in fact Julia if we can
extend Julia or maybe come up with a
super set of Julia we should be able to
use it in a decentralized way and to
unleash a lot of value in uh digital
transform digital transformation for
almost all Industries and this is I
think the the most important uh um area
that I think uh currently uh you know we
can contribute to uh to the community
and also if we can combine uh blockchain
technology together with Julia I think
uh there's a lot more things could
happen and a lot better like economics
could happen and um uh uh very
fortunately uh we are actually uh
developing uh some packages along this
direction and we are happy to uh um
announce we are releasing a the first
part of uh package um and is U um in
this direction is using Julia and if
anyone is interested you can actually uh
contact me uh after the uh the
talk okay so for those who haven't seen
haven't heard about Julia or haven't
used Julia before let me give you a very
very brief introduction of Julia uh
Julia is a high level general purpose
high performance uh crossplatform
dynamic programming languages and what I
mean by high level is um is um it's like
math lab is like python so uh it's very
different from um C C++ it's general
purpose it can work in all kinds of
domains not rest restricted to like
scientific Computing for example it's
high performance like I said is
performance is as good as C plus plus or
rust and it's crossplatform meaning you
can write it once and uh you can execute
on any platform and you don't have to do
this compilation because it's actually
using jlt jit just in time compiler
which is dynamic okay and uh Jula was
originally developed for scientific
Computing numerical Computing and it's
open source and under the MIT license
and uh the four co-founder there and the
paper if you want to read is the Julia
Fresh Approach to numerical Computing
and currently it is in its 1.9 or 1.10
version so it's quite stable already
yeah okay and Julia has uh several
special features that um um I want to
focus on today I mean apart from being
easy to use Dynamic and uh performance
is really great there are two things
that um I think uh differentiat Julia
from other uh programming languages one
is accuracy one the other one is
multiple dispatch and I think these two
um uh special features from the
foundation to extend Julia to be used in
a decentralized programming environment
to build decentralized
systems
and and what I mean by accuracy is that
um most programming languages uh today
um they are built by computer scientists
and pure computer scientist and um but
Julia is different Julia has mathematics
building S at the bottom okay uh let me
give you some examples uh for example
when you want to concatenate two strings
uh in Python we would use the plus sign
okay um but in Julia we use the multiply
the uh the star okay the difference is
that plus is commutative okay you can
swap the position of the two numbers and
it will give you the same number
result but if you do multiplication it
will be different okay two Matrix when
you multiply if you swap the uh the uh
the position is completely different so
in this case uh uh we should use because
for string contamination we shouldn't
swap the position okay
so this the uh the multiply of the the
star sign is actually um I mean
mathematically U is more appropriate
okay and for some basic
statistics um packages for example the
default degre of freedom for calculating
standard deviation in Julia is using n
minus one but in Python is actually M
okay and Julia also takes special care
with approximation okay when you do um
big numerical computation so uh you want
to you know be very very careful with
because when you do a functional
compostion and uh I mean all kinds of
numerical errors Could Happen okay so um
Julia is very very careful with this and
unial support also is very useful
because um sometimes when you want to
translate uh some mathematical formula
algorithm
into programming languages and uh well
if you have this unical supports well
the code is the is the math MTH is the
code okay so that's very uh good for um
you know um working with you know
scientists working with Engineers so
this is very very uh good feature okay
and uh and uh what's even more important
especially in the the recent RM AI um
trend is that um you know accuracy
actually plays a even bigger role you
know it's not just um like just to avoid
numerical error um it actually influence
or or has a big Parts in how you can
achieve
uh a bigger you know RM because um for
example if you look at uh go back to
history uh at the beginning you know
people are using uh fp32 which is a
floating Point single PR and but you
know in uh numerical Computing in
scientific Computing most people would
use 34 64 bit but because you know um
inm uh you want to uh you know have uh
much bigger models with billions of
parameters so you have to you know keep
in uh you know consideration the memory
Footprints okay and um and also the gpus
for example at the beginning most people
are using Nvidia you know Graphics GPU
uh for um training and uh um those gpus
are specifically tuned or optimized for
uh sort of lower Precision uh
arithmetics for example uh single
position 32 bits so in this and also um
uh people in the AI industry also come
up with um fp6 mixed which is sort of um
trying to uh reduce the uh the memory
footprint and also reduce the uh the you
know the
calculation um as much as possible just
to try to accommodate you know bigger
uh RM models okay and uh so they you
know all the all this kind of research
um in the end becomes you know trying to
keep a balance you know where between
memory footprint and all the the
training fine tuning inference speed and
also the prediction Arrow so um I think
Julia has a a very promising future in
this uh regard because um you
know as we have seen most of the big
giants in the AI industry they are
producing specialized chips for example
um Google has TPU you know Amazon has
its own uh chips and uh Apple has its
own chips Microsoft also uning its own
uh machine learning or AI chips so all
of this um uh going to have very
different uh characteristics in terms of
their Hardware in fact um the bf16
format which is a specialized 16bit um
floating Point format proposed by Google
I would you know believe
that Hardware but may not be uh working
the same performance in other um
companies trips so um you know we have
seen all these kind of hog genus we are
seeing hog genus um type of um you know
Computing platforms Hardwares and um you
know in order for any software to be
able to run on this type of um Hardwares
you have to be very flexible you have to
be able to deal with um um this FL
floting Point uh accuracy very carefully
okay and um in addition if let's say um
you have a decentralized envir en for
example some company build like part of
the model okay maybe trained some model
and then need you know um uh uh share
with some other agent uh some other
organization and trying to do something
more and then during this process so um
although the everything was tested in
one organization which is absolutely
fine but when you have two organization
trying to collaborate with each other
things could go wrong because during
this composition a lot of this uh hidden
uh sort of numerical errors could happen
so that's where I think Julia will
shine
okay and um uh the way how Julia uh um
resolved this kind of issue is using
something called a multiple dispatch and
um um in short multiple dispatch
decompose the attributes and methods in
objectoriented programming and um you
can use Str which is Corr corresponds to
attributes and function corresponds to
methods by anyone written by anyone
anywhere at any time but they can be run
together or
independently in any application okay
and this allows total transparency and
uh full control full user control and
this Le the foundation for decentralized
composition as well
and I'm going to illustrate this with an
example you see here we have a toy
example for uh tennis players and we
have an abstract type which is called
tennis player and this is uh like the uh
the higher sort of abstract uh parent
class or parent type depends on how you
call it and then you have uh sub type
which is let's say we have three here
Federal and jovic okay they are all
subtype of the uh of the tennis player
type okay and uh just now uh just uh by
using this okay we are able to uh
instantiate we can create object already
just based on this struct okay which is
not true in object oriented programming
because in oop you have to have the
object you have to have the class which
is well defined attributes which is
function to operate on those FS all
together okay but here in Julia you
don't have to you just need the um the
struct okay and then you can instant
shate
already and then maybe on a different
machine in a different organization you
can write the function that work on
those structs okay so in this case uh
let's say I write a u function called
compete which takes in two players and
one is let's say jovic St the other one
is any player okay and then because
jovic is currently the the
goats he has the most number of grand
slams so uh ja wins most of the for most
players okay so let's say I have this uh
I have Define this compete now in your
application in your organization let's
say you don't like this your favorite uh
player is actually Federal and in fact
when Federal was in his prime he beats
uh jich a lot of times so you can
actually write a another compete
function that takes in same also two uh
uh players one uh J which is same and
then a federal style okay this Federal
style is a sub type of the the general
abstract uh tennis player okay and in
this case it it sort of overrides the
the default um uh compute function and
then uh at run time uh the jit uh
compiler the Julia compiler is able to
uh detect the exact parameter type type
okay and is able to Output uh
differently to uh to give you this uh
full user control okay so if you run it
let's say um we have a j and an adal to
compete with each other J wings but
since I have overwrite I have used
multiple dispatch here um when we
compete uh we have a compete between uh
J and Federal Federal WIS okay so
this is called multiple dispatch it
allows user to
overwrite any function any function
that's um available given to them okay
and this can happen at one time okay so
this is something very very new and I
think this is going to enable a lot of
things um um for old industry of course
you may say uh so what's the big deal I
mean in our organization we have so many
developers we are so efficient so we um
we only use you know uh those big
softwares so very famous softwares and
uh we shouldn't we don't need to like do
this kind of uh uh small
modifications but unfortunately even for
like big open- Source projects softwares
there are limitations okay because
existing open source software or
industry is very easy for read and
execute but they are very expensive or
very difficult to
write um for example in a Quantum hge
fund uh in UK managing about 30 billion
US dollar they are using they were using
uh C+ ++ um for their training systems
and they have to buy a commercial
parallel compiler to compile um their um
treating
system and it's going to take hours so
have they have to do it overnight okay
so to modify
anything it's not easy it's definitely
not easy okay and an example uh two
years ago in November
2021 called lock for Shell this
vulnerability in a very famous Apache
open source project called L 4J actually
demonstrated why it is actually need why
we actually need multiple dispatch okay
because so this of course you can read
the the details here I just um give you
some brief information uh so this um
vulnerability is very serious and has
the highest severity ranking it's it
allows remote code execution and it's
very widespread and it actually affects
93% of all Enterprise Cloud environment
like ews Cloud frare ioud tensent
Alibaba and so on and this is not a new
bu it actually um
existed 10 years ago Okay so this kind
of the bug uh exists but the most
serious thing is this now on the right
you can actually see a Twitter uh uh
message this is actually uh published by
a Chinese uh software engineer in
Alibaba um um Cloud uh company um he
actually uh published this um um book he
discovered it and made it public on
Twitter on November 24th 2021 and he
notified uh uh apart immediately as
well the first exploit reported exploit
happened seven days
later and of course there could be
numerous unreported exploits because you
know companies maybe too shy and don't
want to lose face and they didn't report
it but uh the first reported is seven
days afterwards and
it takes two weeks for the first
official patch from Apache to be
released unfortunately the first patch
was not satisfactory there are still
bucks and it took another nine days to
come up with another patch and then they
found two other two more bucks so they
have to release another Buck fix in 3
days and that wasn't enough and only
until December 28th which is you know 30
plus days after it was first
published this bug was finally
resolved okay it took more than 30
days well I mean in uh some industry for
example uh let's see um uh like uh
e-commerce or maybe some internet
company this is not uh you know so uh
difficult maybe uh their clients could
uh you know tolerate but unfortunately
if you are coming from an industry uh of
let's say Quantum Finance Quantum
trading this is unimaginable this should
be
impossible okay let me give you an
example in 2012 August the
first um a very famous uh of hch fund
actually doing High fre trading ranked
top three called night Capital they had
a bug inside their software and this bug
caused almost half a billion US dollar
lost to this company to the uh night
capital and it made this night Capital
bankrupt and they have to look for
emergency funding and in the end it was
acquired by its
competitor so only 30 minutes was used
for a software bug inside a top top
Quantum headphone very famous for high
frequenc trading to
collapse and in fact in high frequency
traing people are talking about nanc or
microsc so 30 minutes is too
much 30 seconds is enough to take down a
whole quantitive hedge F okay is
definitely
enough so when you talk about a software
bug that needs to be resolved for more
than 30
days I
mean this is unheard of and impossible
in Quantum trading definitely something
has to
change
okay so let me uh give you some
background on Quant trading for those uh
who never heard about Quant trading so
um uh real uh qu trading is actually
scientific Computing in finance so we
have a lot of um um data scientist in
Quant hch fund they're doing data
analytics and they come up with
mathematic models and they try to
predict the market okay and you can
actually differentiate con of hge f
according to the frequency they trade
and also um the type of the the F uh and
also it's s on management okay on the
one
extreme uh on the one extreme you have
uh um high frequency which requires a
lot of speed and on the other hand you
have low frequency but you could have
for uh trillions of dollars and recently
we have seen a lot of uh Trends in
Quantum headphone using tournament to
Outsource is R&D okay this is uh never
happened in the past and also there are
fintech companies founded or supported
by co-founders of top hge fund uh like
Renaissance technology to build similar
type of uh uh platform open source uh uh
uh some software some data to allow data
scientists to uh to contribute and not
only in quantitive trading industry uh
for example uh for PNG and Nova TST
which is in the consumer uh uh Product
Industry in the pharmaceutical industry
people have been using uh decentralized
um you know corporate management um and
they call it OSS movement okay and all
of this actually creates opportunity for
Julia or and some extension of Julia to
be used and to unleash a lot of value in
uh this type of uh movement and uh I
have included uh some references to
books and uh uh papers for you to read
and if you are
interested and whenever you talk about
uh decentralized system and I think most
most people you know consider um
blockchains in fact um uh whenever you
talk about uh uh uh different
organizations or different people trying
to collaborate with each other
definitely you know blockchain will play
a part to for example to reach consensus
for example unfortunately the current um
blockchain or crypto currency industry
has a lot of problem they have hard Fork
um very very uh low TPS it's not
scalable a lot of scans and their
economics is not good because they
didn't create much value and not many
application real application happened on
uh blockchain till today despite so much
money being you know uh invested into uh
this industry so I see um if we could
combine blockchain with Julia or some
extension of Julia I think a lot of
things could happen and a lot of values
can be gener at and um so in summary
what we are trying to uh do here
actually we are actually doing it is to
change the way how software especially
open source are
actually to be developed through
decentralized composition and um uh
currently uh we are developing a series
of packages and the first package is uh
is ready for private evaluation so if
are interested uh you can contact me and
uh this is the QR code for my Linkin and
um please feel free to uh get in touch
and uh um if you have any questions you
can send me uh here or on Linkin and uh
you can request for um a copy of the
software and uh we are very happy to uh
to uh to hear your
feedback okay that's all you